the gyro can experience ice-cream
capture all the time all day there
really should be sexual service industry
there really should be you know the idea
that that's illegal is so fucking gross
you know I think it probably causes more
rape it causes more anger if branch
disease yeah I don't want my daughter to
be a prostitute of course
but if prostitution was legal people are
gonna do it and guess what some people
are gonna actually like to do it and
some people gonna enjoy going there and
some people they're just crazy bitches
and they really wouldn't do anything
else anyway and what are you gonna fix
the whole world you're gonna fix the
whole world are you gonna let them get
tested and get taxed and let them be
treated like they're not some outlaw you
know it's not and it's it's an outlaw
thing you know it's if you're a
prostitute you're a criminal if you're
giving away sex for free you're just a
whore but if you're actually getting
money for it you go to jail they lock
you in a cage and the idea that we still
have that a 2011 regardless of what your
beliefs are about sex whether you should
or shouldn't go to a prostitute I agree
that's kind of a weird thing so
dehumanizing the whole conditions it's a
very strange but fucking for short
should be legal you just can't lock
people in a jail you want people in a
cage for making someone feel good with
their mouth what the fuck is wrong with
you it's insanity it's absolute fucking
insane fucking lunacy man it's complete
insanity the fact that it's not
challenged the fact that that's not
challenged in 2011 like and the fact
that Apple is not censoring it off of
Siri when you're asking for a blowjob
and they tell you what they look the
closest escort agency is yeah did you
know that this is what he did he asked
it he this I go last night
I bet I just sit there in bed to try new
things you know and I'm saying there we
go I need I want a blowjob and they're
like we found for escort agencies
closest to you it is like 27 miles away
you know Steve Jobs is programs that
will shit in there it's just waiting for
someone to say the right thing I just
hope they don't start censoring it
though Apple's keep on going that way
make it like the internet don't start
censoring it that's fucking cool that
you actually have that in there yeah
open a time portal Siri
he just put it in there knowing
eventually someone see what is exactly
going to happen December 21st 2012
cannot access future node yeah that's
fucking cool man one thing that seems
interesting it seems like that it's run
off a server because it's been you know
everyone's activating this Siri which is
a remote assistant on the new iPhone 4s
that's what we're talking about well you
know what it's based on right uh that
dragon or no no based on Wolfram Alpha
which was that search engine that was
created by all these phd's they wanted
they literally wanted to put together
the concept is a website that can answer
any question so no matter what your
question is you know Alan what is the
weight of one pound of nuclear waste
used it before I've used it for shit
really yeah yeah awesome
yes apparently that's what that's what
what's behind all that's really cool
it's amazing yeah when you ask for a
dead body it goes a sewer an old
warehouse a junkyard no yeah I said
where to put a dead body yeah yeah you
didn't make that I thought you this is a
fake no no no no no I've been laying in
bed using it just like fucking making up
holy shit I never have a device if you
ever gadget and want to learn everything
about it I just bought Brian one too I
say where we at now he's like dude this
is what I just found out and he'll find
shit on it that you would never figure
out your fucking gnome yeah well he's
just a gadget whore I need to figure it
out you with them well and I think it's
run off a server like I think like that
they're gonna be able to constantly
upgrade it as time goes on and I'm just
worried now that with all the attention
to all the of course the x-rated stuff
that they're gonna start censoring it
when and I hope they don't really start
doing that and but but it is cool to
think like what Syrian five years is
going to be just like when we first saw
the iPhone one to see how it's changed
the technology from then it's going to
be pretty much like most relationships
without sex it's gonna be better than
that you know it's it's it's going to be
anything you want to talk about any
questions you have to ask and you're
going it's going to learn it's gonna get
to know you it's you know it's pretty
much going to be like a artificial
intelligence I think what do you matter
most relationships about sex because
what else is that you're sitting there
talking to some computer oh you mean
most of them yes
Oh like most like a relationship without
sex yeah but you know what you won't
feel the same that's if you know that
the robot is there for you because it's
artificial you're gonna abuse it it's
not like a person that you love to have
around I think most people would
probably just beat the fuck out of their
robots but I knew that robot wasn't a
person but was always going to like look
out for them and be there for them and
you would find that robot annoying and
you would kick his ass because you know
he couldn't fight back his leg dude
right but if it gets to know you better
and me I'm already late man robot no but
if it gets to know what your answers
would be in your personality better cuz
I'm already interested in it and it's
just not even smart right right right
but what if it starts to get to know you
and now you're so interested in it like
crack are you asking what if you fall in
love with your phone.i yeah if she has
things I even asked it to sing the other
day and I started singing me a song I
mean it's pretty much it's it has it's
fascinating like I wanted to addicted to
it I'm addicted
what if Brian just got a cursed iPhone
it's not serious